this was you know good learning
experience for us we gotta we gotta come
ready to play I don't think we were
locked in from the start unfortunately
and I'm not sure exactly the reason but
I think the focus was there from the
start so we got to look in the mirror
and be very honest about our performance
myself first and then our offense and
our energy and our attention to detail
and we got to get better Aaron Rodgers
after the 26 to eleven loss to the
charges in LA on Sunday obviously Aaron
Rodgers and or one or more of his
teammates candidates for goats of the
week goats in a bad way for week nine we
determined the first pick no longer by
coin toss if you've missed the show for
the past several weeks we now do trivia
question Peter I will pose the question
to you for the first pick in the goat
draft the Ravens are running for more
than 200 yards per game this season most
in the NFL who was the last team to lead
the league in rushing and win the Super
Bowl I'll give you a hint it hasn't
happened in this century I'm gonna guess
the Pittsburgh Steelers
oh it was in 1985 bears which kind of
surprised me that is like a jam time I
remember some Jim McMahon throws that
year especially against the Vikings on a
Thursday night that were very impressive
but apparently they ran they led the
league in rushing so they weren't known
as a passing thing their nose and
offensive team so it's easy to forget
the other stuff all right I'm gonna
begin dovetailing off of the soundbite
that we used my go to the week for week
9 is whoever Aaron Rodgers was referring
to when he said that thing where he knew
damn well what he was saying and sending
a message to someone one or more people
who had screwed up their opportunity to
beat the Chargers good luck fitting out
on the graphic but he Peter we know he
told it Mike Tirico a couple of weeks
ago he knows what he's doing at these
press conferences he doesn't
accidentally blurt something out he was
talking about someone whoever Aaron
Rodgers was talking about when he said
what he said is the go-to the week
whether it's a position group whether
it's one person whether it's the
coaching staff whether it's the defense
whether it's his receivers whoever it is
that he's talking about they're the
goats of the week because they were the
difference between the Packers being the
Packers we've seen all year long and the
team that laid an egg in LA Mike my
number one go-to the week is Adam
Vinatieri the guy who will go down in
history is the best kicker ever
regardless of what Bill Belichick says
guy goes down in history is the best
kicker ever with the most clutch big
kicks had a clutch very big kick to
possibly win a game the Colts really
needed at Pittsburgh Sunday missing a
43-yard field goal so bad that I don't
think it would have made it through if
there were another set of goal posts to
the left of the goal posts and and and
and and let me just say one other thing
about this kick all the Twitterverse
that said immediately and including by
the way the commentators on the game
saying that see you know the laces were
not pointed in the right direction and
that's why he missed it
give me a break he didn't miss this kick
by 10 inches he missed it by 10 yards so
he
didn't miss this he missed it because he
he he hit the earth before the kick and
because he just made a crappy kick and
also in this game Adam Vinatieri missed
his fifth extra point in nine weeks I
mean the Indianapolis Colts no matter
how brave they are right now and how
well they talk of Adam Vinatieri right
now they've got to be thinking are we
smart to at least consider a change at
kicker and they may be getting to that
point soon he was thinking about
retiring after the second week of the
season they talked him out of it Peter
they value his leadership which is
something you rarely hear about a kicker
but they want him to be but you know
this transition from Andrew Luck Colts
to Jacoby perset Colts he's been a big
part of that maybe there's a way you
keep him around you keep him in the
locker room you keep him as part of the
team and you have somebody else who's
actually making the kicks because you're
right that was inexcusable to hit the
ground before you hit the ball
I don't care laces out laces in it was a
Mike Rinder Jack kick remember when Mike
Vanderjagt would have misses like that
for the Colts that were that like he was
trying to put it in the corner where the
seats come together not trying to put it
through the goalposts so I agree with
you on that one the next one for me
minsu mania is over in Jacksonville
Gardner the Ginsu men's shoe you know
he's got a cool mustache and it's a
great story well four turnovers in the
fourth quarter as Nick Foles collarbone
is finally healing is going to get you
benched and it was a horrible
performance not that the Jaguars would
have won the game but you know that I
think the praise of this kid has been
over the top and it probably hasn't
helped him in the grand scheme of things
to have so much heaped upon him and he's
just trying to survive as a sixth-round
pick who's a rookie in the NFL and look
it was not a good game for him it was
not a good game for the jaguars but the
four turnovers in the fourth quarter
cinched it for me goat of the week at
least one of them gardner minshew
Hey look my Gardner Minshew has earned
as the hundred and seventy eighth pick
in the draft he's gonna have a long if
he chooses he's gonna he's gonna have a
long life in the NFL may not have a long
life as a starter but he's gonna have a
long life in the NFL if he chooses
because he can be who wouldn't want him
as the backup quarterback right now the
guy is he's been terrific but he
probably propelled Nick Foles
into being the starting quarterback when
he's ready with that performance in
London on Sunday for my second I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do a group and that is
everyone in Washington who's got
anything to do with the offense and you
know for the third straight week in the
last 12 quarters Mike this team has
scored six field goals and no touchdowns
they have scored zero nine and nine in
the last three games and and and no
matter who their quarterback is no
matter who their coach is it doesn't
matter
and right now what this organization
needs is a total teardown from top to
bottom front office and coaching staff
to give them and a coaching staff and I
don't know who it's going to be but my
head coach when I hire one is going to
be a guy who I trust to rebuild this
passing game and to work with Dwayne
Haskins now who knows whether it's going
to be Eric B enemy Josh McDaniels
whoever it's going to be they need to
get a coach who's going to make sure
that they get everything out of Dwayne
Haskins that they can well you know what
Peter based upon what we saw from the
Vikings in the month of October
offensive coordinator Kevin Stefanski
would have been one of the guys on that
short list of potential Washington
coaches or any way that they're looking
for a coach in 2020 and he still may get
there but I'm gonna give him the goat
horns for my third pick because I keep
thinking about the final half of the
last quarter of Sunday's lost by the
Vikings to the Chiefs the Vikings had
the ball on their own twenty eight with
seven minutes and change to play they're
up by three points and the play calling
from that point
forward in the last two drives for the
Vikings was horrendous a pass on first
and ten when you're in qu the clock mode
and then a highly predictable run that
loses three yards and then on third and
13 you don't trust your quarterback to
throw the ball down the field not that
they should have but come on the guy had
a great month of October trust him to
make the play they run it again and they
basically concede the ball to the Chiefs
the Chiefs tie it up they get the ball
back 2 minutes and 30 seconds to go and
what do they do more throwing the ball
not trusting Dalvin cook not doing the
things that have made the Vikings a team
that that looked as good as any team in
the NFL in month of October so that
sequence of play call in the final two
drives of the game when when the Vikings
had done everything they can they've
worked and fought and scratched and
clawed to be in position to win the game
they blew the lead and then they they
put themselves in position where the
Chiefs scored the game-winning field
goal so Kevin's two fans keep done a
great job this year
very likely will be a head coach next
year but those those play calls made
down the stretch may have very well kept
the Vikings from getting what would have
been a signature win for that team my
third goat is gonna be Mitchell true
Biscay and I feel bad because I feel
like I give him the go-to every week but
this game was lost in the first half the
first 27 minutes of this game Mitchell
tur Biscay an NFL quarterback threw for
five yards and it by the time that they
woke up in the second half they were
down 12 nothing and Mitchell tur Biscay
put him in a hole from which they could
not dig out and and look I've said this
now for two or three weeks the Bears
have to be in win now mode every week
and in my opinion even though he
probably doesn't deserve it because of
how he played chase Daniel in my opinion
should be put in the lineup right now as
much on a mission of mercy for Mitchell
true Biscay than anything else because
it's chase Daniel not true Biscay who
gives the Bears the best chance to win
right now it is amazing how poorly it's
gone how quickly the wheels have come
off for Mitchell true Biscay and the
Bears
I don't know how this happened I don't
know if it's a matter of it being as
simple as defenses had a full year to
look at what Matt naggy was doing with
Mitchell true Biscay and they put the
clamps on it or they don't have a
running game I don't know what it is I
don't know if it's Nagy more than its
true Biscay but there is definitely a
ceiling on true Biscay he's regressed
and and it just makes it even more
glaring Peter that Patrick mahomes and
deshaun Watson were on the board when
they traded up to get true Biscay in the
line of the week this week for me came
from marks Lera during that game as true
Biscay was getting swallowed up by
Eagles defenders he said the Sharks are
in the water and Mitchell true Biscay is
a bag of chum and that's exactly how it
went so all right let's recap and let's
see what they put on the ground for my
first pick if they can fit it on their
roster that's good that's good Rodgers
message recipients or or or plural
Gardner Minshew the second Kevin
Stefanski Peter has admitted Terry the
Washington offense and Mitchell true
bisque
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports